the United States is exceptional at
least when it comes to being the world's
biggest jailer 2.2 million people are
imprisoned in the u.s. more than in any
country in the world more than even
China who Dwarfs US population wise when
you count the people who aren't just
incarcerated but on probation or parole
the numbers skyrockets to six point nine
million that's one in 35 American adults
caught up in the prison system and for
people of color it's even worse one out
of every three African American men born
today will go to jail or prison at some
point in their lives but why how did the
so-called land of the free put so many
of its own citizens behind bars if you
think it was always like this it wasn't
back in the 1960s our incarceration
rates were the same as Europe and if you
think there's just more crime here
that's not true either
our crime rates are pretty much on par
with the rest of the Western world
I asked Elysia Santo a staff writer at
the Marshall project for some insight
the reason that America has the highest
incarceration rate to put it simply it's
tough on crime policies over the past
few decades a number of very harsh
policies have been enacted in state and
federal legislatures a lot of these had
to do with longer sentences some of
these had to do with so-called
three-strikes laws which basically said
that if you got in trouble three times
you had to be in prison regardless often
how petty those crimes were to get a
sense of how prison happy Americans are
consider that in Germany only six
percent of people convicted get locked
up
compare that to 70 percent of people
convicted in the US and Americans wind
up behind bars for longer the average
sentence in the u.s. is three years
that's three times longer than in
Germany harsh drug laws are also part of
the top
the 1986 anti-drug Abuse Act instituted
a mandatory minimum sentence of five
years without parole for possession of
five grams of crack guess how much
cocaine you had to possess to trigger
the same minimum sentence 500 grams
interesting when you look at who
consumed each drug more even though the
law was recently relaxed we're still
dealing with its effect and overall
black and white people use drugs at the
same rate but black men are almost 12
times more likely than white men to go
to prison on drug offences finally when
it comes to our soaring prison
population mental health also plays a
role about half of all incarcerated
people suffer mental health problems for
10 to 25% of all prisoners that means
serious mental illnesses like
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder drug
and alcohol dependence is also common
and instead of getting help many
mentally ill people cycle through the
system over and over again but it's not
just the mentally ill who struggled to
escape the cycle being convicted of a
felony can follow someone long after
their time is served
it can make getting a job housing and an
education even harder and it also often
means losing the right to vote in
Florida and Virginia both key swing
states and national elections more than
one in five black people are
disenfranchised but the prison boom
hasn't been so bad for everyone private
prison corporations like Corrections
Corporation of America and geo group are
actually profiting from it the
Corrections Corporation of America made
1.6 billion dollars in revenue in 2014
alone this is all part of what's called
the prison industrial complex and when
one in 35 of us is directly caught up in
it you got
just how free are
the words jail in prison are often used
interchangeably but actually describe
two different kinds of institutions in
the u.s. the main difference between
them is